Hsu: Hi. I'm Allan Hsu
from imeem.
And I wrote the imeem
application for Android.
When you start
the application,
we give you a series
of, uh, default stations
that you can listen to.
But you can also search
for some of your favorite bands.
One of my favorite bands
is Death Cab for Cutie.
Now I'm listening to the Death
Cab for Cutie station.
On the station,
we also present new artists
that are similar
to Death Cab for Cutie,
um...
and, uh,
among other
Death Cab for Cutie songs.
Uh, if I like this station,
I can actually, uh,
choose to Favorite the station.
And now, when I go back,
Death Cab for Cutie's been added
to my Favorites station.
We decided to build
this application
for the Android platform
because we thought the platform
was a really good fit
for our existing user base.
We built the very se--
search-centric, uh,
user experience on the phone
around, uh,
the SQLite databases
on the phone
as well as, uh, the Java
Regular Expressions engine.
We used, uh,
the Apache HTTP components
as well as
the JSON libraries
and the, uh, Java Crypto
frameworks
to integrate
with our web services API.